the end of the day
we are investing in a product at the
early stages
right so for us you know for you as an
early stage vc it's about the founders
for us it's about the managers right
we're really trying to understand
what differentiates these people to make
them special a lot of ways that's what
you're looking for when you're doing a
direct investment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
meet amit kultz general partner at
sweetwood ventures an israel-focused
venture capital fund of funds
prior to co-founding swedenwood ventures
amit was a lawyer at apm and co where he
represented private equity and venture
capital funds and high-tech companies in
all of their corporate and commercial
affairs
amit was previously recognized by forbes
as one of israel's brightest leaders
under the age of 30 forbes 30 under 30
and he holds a master's degree in
business administration majoring in
management of technology innovation and
entrepreneurship at tel aviv university
[Music]
amit cool welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
from tel aviv how are you
good michael how you doing
hey i'm doing well i'm i'm looking
forward to spending the next 20 minutes
diving deep as deep as we can in 20
minutes into
um you know what you're doing and what
are you doing with fund of funds and
with the israeli investment
ecosystem and talking a little bit about
sweetwood ventures and how you see
investments in this domain how you see
investments in this technology and and
the differentiation between fund of
funds versus direct investments and how
your own personal journey is intertwined
within all this so it's going to be a
really fun 20 minutes and thank you very
much for being here fantastic thanks
thanks for hosting a pleasure to be here
looking forward to this
well tell me just a little bit about
sweetwood ventures what is this what is
this organization that you're a general
partner at and you've been there for for
quite some time and then i'd love to
talk a little bit higher level about the
ecosystem and how you fit into it yeah
fantastic so sweet to adventures we're
essentially a fund of fund for israeli
vc uh we today manage about 250 million
dollars across two flagship funds the
smaller stores with much more of a
dedicated strategy towards smaller
managers um our first fund was launched
in 2018 our second fund was launched um
in 2021.
really our idea and what we try to do at
sweetwood is to allow our investors to
invest in a diversified approach into
israeli venture capital right so our job
is basically to select the best funds on
the market we have a very focused
approach
because we only like to invest in a
select number of managers are really our
agenda what we try to do is you know
invest in a top 10 percent of bond
managers in the local ecosystem in
israel
um and then what we do so we allocate 70
of our assets towards investing in what
you call primary investments into these
managers so we just come to a fund and
we start investing with them when the
fund starts um and then we combine with
that strategy we do 15 of secondaries
and funds so we buy more mature
positions which is a way for us to kind
of ease the j-curve and the liquidity
profile of typical venture capital fund
which usually take a long time until
they distribute returns and capital back
to investors the last part that we do is
we basically double down on some of our
quan'z winners so we work very closely
with our portfolio managers and we
co-invest with them and some of their
top uh companies today we have a
portfolio of about 10 fund managers that
we've invested with them with some of
them we've already invested across two
vintages so we invested our first one we
obviously you know really want to follow
all of our managers our agenda is to
invest with our managers over decades
you know in multiple vintages um and
yeah we're today in the middle of
rolling out our second vintage and you
know things are looking
pretty cool and uh you know fun science
incredible so i'm hearing three
different pillars as to what what
swedewood really is about what one of
which is this is the idea of you know
investing in funds it's a fund of funds
selecting the top uh fund managers in
the israeli ecosystem and investing
directly in them
or
directing them meaning the fund but then
you have this 15 percent in order to
purchase shares in in more mature areas
of the fund so not necessarily the first
closing when they're still
you know who knows what what the
portfolio will be like now you have some
indication but then also being able to
double down on the winners tell me a
little bit about
fund of funds as a concept you know the
process of investing in a fund rather
than perhaps a direct investment
right so i think there's you know funded
funds is an interesting business right i
think there are similarities in a lot of
ways to sort of early stage investments
right in the end of the day
we are investing in a product at the
early stages which is really the
fountain right so for us you know for
you as an early stage vc it's about the
founders for us it's about the
management right we're really trying to
understand
what differentiates these people to make
them special a lot of ways that's what
you're looking for when you're doing a
direct investment so there's some
similarities in that the non-similar
things are really you know we're not
looking for them to grow in scale on
building a product because their product
is making successful investments and our
job as as as you know lps and investors
and funds is to look at how they think
how they operate what brings them value
why do they get access to the best you
know entrepreneurs in the market and how
is that going to trick the law over the
next decade because you know when we
invest in funds we're investing across
very long-term horizons so we're really
really looking to build partnerships for
decades and like i said you know more
than decades with these fund managers
and see how they can excel
for the long run by investing now you
mentioned something really interesting
which is you know how do we also do
secondaries next to that and
co-investments which are a bit you know
different skill sets right because fun
analyzing is really your job is to
understand managers you know when you do
secondaries or when you do
co-investments your job is much more to
understand you know direct investments
but we really believe that actually our
fund investments are the catalysts that
allow us to understand the direct
investments a lot better because we
build this phenomenal network of a lot
of gps in our in our you know close
network we're investors of gps you know
we get access to internet information we
can track companies we can interact with
these gps learn about what's going on in
these companies and then really zone in
on those winners and that allows us to
get you know multiple points of view
over what's going on in the direct
startups and we feel that that gives us
an extra layer of insight that you know
normal investors they're just scanning
the market and don't enjoy the
leveraging of the network that we built
for fund the fund
investment strategy in jewel
the discussion that i that i want to
have a little bit is about
you know the process in which one
decides
what fun to invest in so what
information do you have what is the sort
of the process that you're going through
to determine whether this is a group or
this is a fund
that you want to invest in as a whole
perhaps in comparison to how you would
invest in a direct company
right so so first of all like i think
what you have when you invest in a fund
is is is it's tracker right which is a
place where you start it gives you a
good entry point because you can see
what the manager has done in the past
and you know one of the funny things is
that you know in finance the first rule
when you go into finance class 101 is
like you know past performance does not
predict future performance well that's
wrong when you talk about venture
capital right if you look at historical
data globally um and also if you look
actually at some research we've done on
the israeli vc market specifically
the probability of a top quartile
manager to consistently outperform
meaning to stay as a top quarter let's
say second quartile or worse is actually
quite significant in venture capital
right so only about three or four
percent
of venture capital managers between
their vintages move from being a first
quartile manager to last quarter manager
right now if you think about it that
makes a lot of sense when you look at
venture capital right because venture
capital is an asset where brand has this
sort of cyclicality motion to it right
so how do brands like let's say sequoia
right the best example bro in the world
of brand creation right sequoia started
investing had great entrepreneurs right
built a great track pivot what happens
next entrepreneurs recognize that
sequoia was able to invest in great
companies they want to get capital from
sequoyah so sequoia continues to have
this cyclicality effect for the last
almost 50 years of getting attracted and
building his brand and that creates a
new cyclicality effect where you're
getting more exposure and greater access
to the best funds so for us the first
thing when you walk in the door you know
the first thing we want to see is kind
of like okay what have you done
and we clearly know that this is
probably going to have an indication
implication of what you will do right
and that's kind of step one um then from
there so just to make sure that really
given that doesn't make sense to assume
that
and it doesn't make sense to assume that
funda that you know first time
venture capitalists
perhaps fund the funds is not
necessarily the right avenue for them as
they're fundraising because they just
don't have enough information to provide
to the
fund the funds to give indication as to
what's going to happen right yeah so so
it's a great question so so the answer
is yes and no right obviously when you
have less of a track record less of
experience it's obviously harder to
raise for more institutional investors
like us
right having said that we always look
for new emerging managers um we always
want to interact we always want to know
them um you know the end result and the
probability that your raise is probably
low in the end of the day you know we do
three investments every year right we
only invest in three managers and most
of these managers are managers that
we've already invested in but we try to
keep an opening always open for new
managers it's just that the probability
that you'll get an allocation we
probably see 30 new managers a year
there's probably one or two allocations
that you're fighting for so you really
need to excel inside these group of
managers um in order to warrant a ticket
so what i'm saying is kind of like it
definitely is possible but it is a
harder task as an emerging manager and
and you see that across the board with
statistics the interesting thing is by
the way about emerging managers is they
actually tend to outperform the market
so if you look at a benchmark or
emerging managers which is vintage's
emerging managers usually describe in
our universe like well first vintage or
third vintage
um
statistically they tend to perform
better than more established managers um
over huge data sets like if you look at
the us market that has been the case so
for us we we understand this data right
and we understand that we need to create
an art portfolio the supply and balance
between
getting new managers into our portfolio
but still keeping allocation to our
established managers by the way as a
side note one of the things that we do
actively in order to continue engaging
with these new managers are coming is we
built this program called sweden nextgen
um it's basically a program that sort of
tries to teach you everything about
venture that has nothing to do with
investing so how do you build a fund how
do you structure a fund
legal work how do you speak to lps how
do you build a deck how do you build a
data right we have a lot of smart people
out there that never raise the fund and
there's a lot of you know
not art but science right there's a lot
of processes that you need to go and
things you need to do to um to get them
to the most efficient process and end up
raising capital so what we did is is we
opened a you know free registration
program
we had huge demand for this we had about
70 people apply we ended up selecting
eight of really who we believe are the
next emerging stores of israeli vc you
know we have people from top fives like
nfx tlv
um really top participants you can see
it over our linkedin page of what we've
done and you know we did a process of
these people for eight sessions
top interactions with all the best
investors in the world we brought big
fund of funds big institutionals big
family offices top lawyers to speak to
them
and you know that gives us a great
opportunity to be intimate with these
people right and then if i end this by
saying how do you want to raise this
emerging manager
build relationships right start
interacting with people like us early
start building a repertoire you know
just meet with us for cough right come
to get our advice you know
and the longer we spend
the more we spend time with you the
better we'll get to know you the higher
the probability will invest in you once
that takes place once you've partnered
with fund managers you mentioned that
you do about
three of those a year well what is sort
of the day-to-day like look so so you
mentioned that you're very data driven
and and obviously then you you do have
the ability to double down on on winners
and secondaries for for funds that are
more mature
so what what is sort of the day-to-day
look like for you once you've already
sort of decided okay these are the funds
that we're gonna work with for now we're
not stressed and deploying more capital
as of now but we want to still you know
make sure that we're that that we're
positioning ourselves correctly so what
what is it that you do at that point
so so so for us the way we look at it is
we don't want to be passively we don't
want to be the guys that just deploy
capital and you don't speak with for the
next couple of years right
at the same time we don't want to be too
cumbersome on our gps right we want to
give the value that we can bring to the
table but only if they want to take it
so the way i i like to phrase it is
we're kind of almost at the service of
our gps you know there's places where
you can add a ton of value you know we
have a lot of experience around how to
fundraise right you need connections to
other lp's we have those in our network
um for example we had a manager um that
had a very interesting uh gp led
secondary done his fund right that's a
very complex transaction
we've done it ourselves we've been part
of the other side of gp led transactions
you know we were you know i think at
least from our side we felt we were very
meaningful for this gp in that process
you know us being able to give feedback
understand what's going on the second
place where we try to help and interact
a lot with gps is we see a lot and we
have a lot of data so we try to a
produce reports
and b speak to our gps you know now that
you know there's obviously some turmoil
going on through financial markets you
know we're usually i hope to so are one
of the first vocals of our gp's because
we see a lot of things are going on
everybody's kind of calling us
everybody's speaking to us and they're
trying to understand what their peers
are doing what their colleagues are
doing which approaches are we seeing
that historically work in these type of
environments
and that's kind of our day-to-day you
know after we deploy the portfolio
there's a lot of work or just
understanding what's going
on in the portfolio adding value and the
last part i would say i like to call
this like our hidden like ongoing due
diligence
the reality is that we're always do
diligency right as opposed to a startup
investment you invest once yes you're
going to continue to do this for the
follow-on round we continue to do
diligence for the next fun right so we
try to interact with our gbs try to
understand what they're doing good well
what they're not doing so well at and
then that allows us to come in when they
come to raise our next one a lot smarter
right we already kind of have a good
idea of whether we want to continue
which 99 of design the answer is yes
right but we have a better knowledge and
a better understanding of how this gr gp
operates simply because we worked with
it with them for a few years already
incredible i mean where do you fit into
this so
you know if working in fund of funds not
not a likely position in venture capital
today i assume that the vast majority of
of funds in the vc world are direct
funds
where sort of your head in terms of
where you're at and and your position
within this ecosystem
that's so i i love
our place right we're we're sort of like
a vc but we're not a vc and i think that
plays really well with a few things
right i think it plays well with my
personal dna right i think what we're
very good at is
understanding fund managers we're
getting better obviously doing direct
investments we have a phenomenal
portfolio but we're learning how to do
that we all call myself and my partners
for the legacy of being you know fun
selectors and manager selectors
and and i personally you know i i love
doing this for the phone works right um
i think for me also
i have huge conviction in the small i
when when when i started this journey at
that sweet adventures when we came here
we said okay we're building a fundament
i'll be honest i i was not convinced
this is how you should be investing
um in venture capital and then i started
digging into a lot of the data and a lot
of the research about fund the funds and
venture capital and when you
think about venture capital right so
there's a few interesting
things about it it's it's a game of
access but it's also a game of access at
the fun level right with some of our
funds it's not about us being able to
give 10 million dollars it's about them
accepting us and investors okay now if
you look at it fund the funds
tend to have better access than a common
investor right so one of the things
we're selling is access the second thing
that we're selling is expertise right
we do this every day
we engage with the market we feel that
we have better insights to do a better
job than a normal investor just walking
in and selecting a few funds now how
does that translate to me really
believing in the fundamental structure
is the fact that fund the funds
actually outperform
at the median
venture capital foot
which think about that for a second
right fund the funds and everybody will
tell you we have another layer of fees
should be more expensive that's actually
a role the median fund the fund
outperforms the media and venture of
capital fund globally historically this
is obviously validated data
now
obviously
a particular fund
has an ability to probably return you
know six or seven or eight decks the
probability that you're going to have
that type of outlier return and fund the
fund is lower because we are more
diversified now for us at sweetwood the
trick is how do you become diversified
to reduce risk but don't reduce too much
risk
and that's where i really believe in
what we're doing so what we do is we
don't invest in a lot of funds we only
invest in eight managers because we want
to make sure that these eight or nine
managers will really have an impact so
if one of our manager is going to return
10 or 15x or even 7x right that's going
to have a meaningful impact so our fund
of fund can generate alpha now if you
take that and combine that with a bit of
diversification that we have
for me on on a risk-adjusted basis for
most investors right accessing a country
like israel from a refund the fund
perspective just makes a lot of sense
and if i had to step back and redo this
and say hey where would i want to put my
money
i'm very convinced that a fund of fund
is a great tool for many investors to
invest in vc and that's where this thing
kind of catches me
i love it i mean thank you so much for
spending these 20 minutes with me uh
not not every day that that i get to do
an episode with it with a fun of funds
especially in the israeli market and
it's and it sounds like
and i love the
the way that you're thinking through
swedenwood ventures you know we're we're
a vc but we're not really a vc well
we're kind of like a vc but not really
because you have you do have the
beautiful parts of the vc but also the
beautiful parts of not being a vcn and
having the ability to to take your time
to proper diligence to to back
a diversified portfolio but then double
down where it really counts and and
being meaningful and it sounds like a
really meaningful partner to those that
you partner with so thank you very much
for joining me i appreciate the time and
uh and your contribution to our
ecosystem and best of luck with
sweetwood and stay safe and stealthy
[Music]